I want to know about the eyesight for
relationship is this priority now
yeah it's like
it's since I it's since I was a little
kid I was like since my dad died I was
like oh I can't wait to have a kid and
like
again I don't like saying corny [ __ ]
like the the reasoning was I because I
was like I don't want a kid to ever feel
like how I feel right now okay so like
just to be like it wasn't his fault it
passed away but just to be there and so
that someone doesn't have to feel like
that and I've just like been very
excited to do that for someone and have
that and watch yeah watch them have what
I didn't okay you know what I mean okay
it's the idea of marriage with the kid
or 100 I mean I hope it goes but you
know
all right yeah when you say feel like I
feel now was there ever a was ever a
therapeutic Point did you have to go to
therapy did you have to go down I was in
therapy I had I mean everybody has it
but I when I was like six they were like
you have 80d so I started seeing a
therapist with the family and then I got
better and then like a month later my
dad died and they were like well welcome
back to therapy so I've been in therapy
since I'm seven okay like at least twice
a week okay for 21 years okay so I'm at
a point where I'm like
sometimes it's really nice I go back and
forth where like I'm like this is really
great to talk to somebody and another
time I'm like why the [ __ ] am I I have
homies like we they give me better
advice or but uh you know when you deal
with like mental health stuff and you
have mental health stuff and people are
aware that you have mental health stuff
I always want to make sure I'm doing
everything I can
that you um can do to better that
situation has your circle changed my
circle has changed drastically I've
learned so much in the last two three
years like you know you just learn
someone's a user someone is pretending
to be your best friend but really has an
ulterior motive or
you know this person's only in it for
this and you know it sucks it's really
sad like because you really care about
this people and then now I'm at a place
where I'm like okay I got my four or
five I'm like we're good what does your
down time look like what does Pete
Davidson do to shut off I'm a [ __ ]
loser I love like I can't say that too
no dude I smoke weed I mean as of now I
don't know what it says but right now I
smoke weed I watch like 90 Day Fiance
Pawn Stars Wars I watched like I've I
just thought of dude I just started
watching Flavor of Love what are you
talking about bro that [ __ ] is hilarious
like I'm so jealous you guys got to grow
up with that Flavor of Love bro that's
like
he's always just like three hours late
eating a crab so shocked that
something's going on yeah like it's his
show you gotta be kidding me like oh man
I met him and he's that's what he is
that's who he is wow great flavor
flavors one of the most entertaining
people you ever meet I've never been
more entertained in my life flavor
flavor do it so I've been watching like
that and I'm a movie buff see every
movie that comes out I have a highly
opinionated opinion on every single
thing but I usually keep to myself with
like other homies I just like to hang
and watch movies like with my friends by
the way that's funny as hell right there
Pete Davidson's Pete Davidson's take on
your your Blockbusters of today oh yeah
be sitting at home and being like
licorice pizza is
why didn't even give a [ __ ] about my
movie
[Music]